[Musique]
bonjour marie france tour bonjour
mondial tant bonjour à vous auditeurs et
auditrices de martinique 1ère secrétaire
général adjoint du rassemblement
démocratique de la martinique
vice-présidente de l'assemblée est
candidate depuis une semaine à la
députation sur fort-de-france à la
deuxième candidature du rdm après celle
de christian verneuil dans le centre
atlantique il y en aura-t-il d'autres de
votre formation politique on and soul
allons l'air dm effectivement qui est
parti mal gérée en martinique après
avoir consulté les différentes sections
le conseil politique nous avons donc
opté pour que le ndm soit présent sur
trois circonscriptions sur les 4
c'est-à-dire la circonscription centre
déjà avec le camarade de christian
verneuil avec moi même si au fort de
france et également pour le moment nous
sommes entrés encore de de réfléchir et
de travailler à une éventuelle
candidature pour le nom des personnes
dans le sud face à jorf innocente
nous sommes fidèles un autre à notre
alliance au terme de notre alliance qui
prévoyait que dans l'alliance nous ne
devions pas nous n'était pas convenu que
nous présentions de candidat contre un
membre de l'alliance sortant pourquoi
cette frénésie du rdm de ces frais des
idées aux partis politiques qui nous
avait habitués c'est vrai des réunions
de centaines de personnes et qui ne le
fait plus beaucoup de bruit depuis
quelques temps je crois qu'on a eu un
débat déjà là dessus aujourd'hui nous
nous sommes recentrés sur vraiment des
choses essentielles avec de véritables
militants avec de véritables causes
évitables militants nous avons mis
l'accent sur des mobilités informations
mais on a bien vu quand vous avez un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
arrivées au parti et qui à la moindre
difficulté au moindre secousse mais ont
laissé le navire ce n'était pas vraiment
des militants s'ils raid et
sympathisants s'étaient d1d rang au plus
tôt mais ce n'était pas de véritables
militants et aujourd'hui fort de ses
militants fort de ses sections
fort de ce travail qui a été solide à
sion le terrain et andy à la bataille
des législatives c'est parce que c'est
le rdm apport son secrétaire général
claude lise quelques maires qui continue
à rouler avec lui mais on ne sait pas
combien vous êtes sais pas qui vous êtes
vous sait même pas s'il pourra retrouver
et le rdr se rassemblent je vous ai dit
que le rdr est un parti majeur nous
avons notre secrétaire général nous
avons notre secrétaire général claude
lise qui est président de l'assemblée où
elle même je suis à l'assemblée nous
avons christiane bouras et qui est une
élue qui fait un travail formidable au
sein de la de la collectivité
vous avez un gène l'arche et puis on a
encore plus aux menaces que nous
réunissons régulièrement les sections
temps dans le nom nous avons une très
grande section sur l'euro béant nous
avons une section à sept maris nous
avons une section au carbet nous avons
une section où la montée donc le ndm
travail ne sont pas là pour simplement
faire du bruit lorsqu'il y a des rendez
vous importants vous allez nous entendre
une d'accord pour porter quel discours
nous allons porter le discours du mdm
qui est un disque ont fondé sur les
valeurs de la démocratie sur les valeurs
du socialisme démocratique c'est un lien
nous voulons plus de solidarité dans
cette société qui devient de plus en
plus individualiste nous voulons
également une
une économie nouvelle nous voulons un
disque où est une manière différente de
faire la politique qui place vraiment
l'homme au coeur de nos préoccupations
de l'église nocturne du rdr votre
candidature sur fort de france
c'est exactement ça donc je vous ai dit
et en dm nous avons considéré
qu'aujourd'hui le mdm avait toute sa
place à prendre dans dans cette bataille
des législatives et que nous avons un
disque aux attentes et que nous avons
notre contribution aussi apporter pour
faire en sorte que nous ayons une
société comme je vous ai lu dit qui soit
plus juste parce qu'aujourd'hui vraiment
les martiniquaises les martiniquais sont
en difficulté les entreprises sont en
difficulté et nous avons vraiment cette
foule mais non de porter ce n'est pas
notre la marche très bien depuis un
certain décembre 2015 les analystes
dirigeante l'âme avec de nouveaux
dirigeants à nyon qui font que ça
s'améliore la martinique va mieux mais
vous savez nous avons trouvé un passif
tellement consistant à bruxelles nous
n'allons pas ça fait plus seulement
comme de se réfugier derrière c'est la
réalité aujourd'hui nous avons
effectivement se pâtit faux bond nous
avons pu le rattraper énormément de
retard maintenant nous sommes comment
dirais-je en capacité bain de faire
mieux mais il y a des difficultés puis
vous savez les choses ne se règle pas de
coup de baguette magique faut vraiment
travailler
c'est une pierre que nous allons
apporter vous savez lorsque vous voulez
améliorer les choses mais il faut poser
les premiers il faut poser des jalons et
c'est ce jalon que nous allons que nous
allons porter cette contribution que
nous allons porter parce que aujourd'hui
nous sommes conscients que nous avons
des collectivités qui sont en difficulté
nous sommes conscients que je vous ai
dit sur le social y un certain nombre de
choses à faire et que beaucoup des lois
qui sont votées discuté au parlement ont
un impact sur notre société
martiniquaise pourquoi ne pas se
concentrer sur une tâche sur une
fonction sur mandat il ya tellement de
choses afférentes au sein de cette
assemblée
pourquoi vouloir aller encore à la
députation pourquoi ne pas confier cette
mission à quelqu'un d'autre sont de ceux
ci gros party que ça mais vous savez il
y a une capacité que chacun peut avoir
il y à des choix politiques qui sont
faits et aujourd'hui je considère que
après mon parcours politique
deux militantes après mon expérience en
tant que responsable politique je suis à
même de pouvoir représenter dignement où
mon parti comme le christian verneuil
également et il faut une expérience
politique
il fait alors oui je ne suis pas cumuler
olemps ii puisque il n'ya comme on
dirige et je considère plutôt que je
suis dans la complémentarité et puis je
fais part entier d'aider des élus qui
est aujourd'hui consacre vraiment où
tout leur temps tout leur dynamisme
un moment d'un hameau à mes mandats
d'élu et c'est pour moi ma masse mama le
vrai politicien je suis une femme
politique je suis une femme politique
politicienne
une femme politique responsable qui
prend conscience que dans ce pays dans
la matinée qu'il y a des difficultés et
qu'il faut vraiment qu'on soit
responsable et il ya de plus en plus de
difficultés en martinique selon qu'on
s'implique
dans la vie politique il ya de plus en
plus de difficultés à martini et les uns
des difficultés en martinique il y avait
nombre de choses donc vous et morisot
des transporteurs mécontents des
artistes mécontents mais à qui la faute
vous savez je vous ai dit que nous avons
au passif parce que quand on regarde les
les transporteurs il s'appuie sur une
décision qu'ils disent qu'ils avaient
été prises avec l'ancienne majorité et
on n'a pas trouvé de traces de traces
donc il y à déjà slam il n'y a pas que
ça il y a aussi le fait que nous sommes
dans un système français qui aujourd'hui
s'appuie beaucoup sur des références des
normes françaises et qui ne
correspondent pas et qui ne sont pas
adaptés aux réalités des autres maires
que pensez vous pouvoir apporter à votre
circonscription que pensez vous pouvoir
apporter à la martinique que le sortant
ne fait pas assez suffisamment selon
vous mais c'est apporter une regard
global sur l'ensemble du territoire
sur l'ensemble de la martinique parce
que lorsque vous êtes député d'une
circonscription vous n'êtes pas
seulement député de cette
circonscription
vous êtes député dans l'ensemble
français comme un tollé la tête de loi
qui porte son nom et oui ça ne sonne ça
ne c'est pas parce que vous avez texte
de loi qui porte votre nom que vous avez
fait avancer les choses et que pour
autant les choses ont réellement été
pensé dans un sens global et pour
l'intérêt de la martinique alors que
free veut plus là aujourd'hui c'est un
regain global ce sont des propositions
sur l'ensemble du territoire ils n'ont
pas des comment dirais-je ddd partie des
projets de loi parce que nous avons eu
au niveau du rdr mais nous avons eu
notre secrétaire général claude lise qui
était député et qui a travaillé autour
de la loi d'orientation et c'est dans
cette idée
c'est dans cette idée c'est sur cette
conception que nous allons travailler et
apporter notre contribution dernière
dernières questions mais très rapidement
les éventuels candidats dans le nord ce
serait trop quand on le sera quand même
très bientôt
merci beaucoup marie-france soul on
rappelle que vous êtes candidate dans la
circonscription de fort de france pour
la législative de jeu prochain merci
bonne journée
[Musique]
des grecs